[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Georges Arthur forest vous vous
définissez comme un Africain blanc
qu'est-ce qu'un Africain blanc
je définis comme à l'imprimer qu'un
blanc parce que je suis né là-bas je me
considère comme un africain mais je suis
blanc donc ça c'est un côté stable donc
ça serait difficile de dire je suis pas
un blanc mais je reste africain parce
que vous êtes né il faut le dire je suis
né au Congo dit belge à l'époque à
l'époque en 1940 donc ouais et vous avez
acquis la nationalité belge si je ne
m'amuse 1995 seulement parce qu'au
départ j'étais j'avais la nationalité
nous irlandaise
et puis c'est l'histoire de votre
famille ça voilà et comme je me suis
marié avec une belle à l'époque qui est
décédée malheureusement très jeune qui
était belge donc j'ai demandé la
nationalité belge et parce qu'on faisait
les affaires avec la Belgique on allait
régulièrement en Belgique c'était en
Europe pour moi c'était plus facile
d'être belge et on fait mes études aussi
mais au fond de vous même vous êtes
africains je suis africain profondément
congolais
congolais de République démocratique du
Congo oui parce que j'ai vécu tout le
temps là et toutes nos activités sont là
est-ce que vous avez souffert du racisme
pour autant des Noirs vis-à-vis des
blancs
personnellement non
jamais non de faite même quand on était
jeune on jouait avec les
Africains on s'est dit à l'école avec
des africains ou à l'époque il y a pas
tellement mais les quelques-uns qui
étaient là c'était des bons amis oui
venez à la maison on discuter avec eux
et que j'ai appris la langue parce que
vous parlez plusieurs langues
ça veut dire pas de problème d'accord
jambes
et vous parliez swahili dès votre plus
jeune âge alors le mot jeune âge je
parle avec les Congolais qui parle
souvent
les autorités d'accord et quand il y a
eu des problèmes parce qu'il y a eu des
problèmes de moult problèmes en
République démocratique du Congo qui
s'est appelé à un moment le Zaïre
d'ailleurs du temps de Mobutu vous avez
vécu notamment
quand louezie et cette prise d'otage
collezie en 1978 où on sait très bien
que l'armée française est intervenue et
vous avez pas craint pour votre vie là
parce que ce qu'on attaquait c'était les
intérêts occidentaux justement sur place
effectivement bon enfin ils ont attaqué
mais ils sont venus chez nous quand ils
sont venus me faire prisonnier ou bon
nous ont voulu m'exécuter ils vous ont
voulu vous exécuter ils m'ont mis au mur
mais sans mettre ailleurs qui m'ont
sauvé en se mettant devant
ce sont vos salariés africains qui
étaient ceux qui étaient un miroir mais
mon personnel dans la maison et d'autres
qui étaient mieux
parce que sinon il voulait vous tuer les
amis de la France j'étais un ami de mon
bouton un sale capitaliste pas
nécessairement mais capitaliste
après bon comme ils sont mis devant et
travailler ils ont été étonnés donc ils
ont demandé qu'ils se retire mais de fil
en aiguille j'ai pu placer un mot de mon
dans la langue en swahili donc on a eu
un dialogue à ce moment-là ils m'ont dit
bon ok on attend on va demander au chef
puis après quelques temps après ils
m'ont dit on vous garde prisonnier j'ai
été gardé comme ça avec une quarantaine
de personnes dans la propriété alors on
vous en voulez parce que vous êtes un
homme d'affaires que vous êtes à la tête
d'un groupe économique fort important
qui a été dont les fondations ont été
bâties par votre grand-père mon père
votre père et vous vous avez développé
tout cela donc vous êtes présent dans le
domaine bancaire dans le domaine minier
dans l'aviation on était dans la version
aussi dont on est dans l'agro industrie
on est dans dans l'agriculture bâtiment
tous les domaines on a été dans
plusieurs domaines maintenant c'est
limité à 3 domaines qui sont c'est
l'énergie BTP les routes et
la croix industrie la grande industrie
et donc c'est à ce titre là que vous
avez parce qu'on estimait que vous étiez
riche et que vous exploitiez finalement
vous voyez comme un travailleur sont
interdit parce que les travailleurs j'ai
une eau vivent dans les bonnes
conditions nous faisons beaucoup de
social aussi pour la population nous
avons quand même des hôpitaux des écoles
des autonome beaucoup de choses dans
pour développer développer faire
beaucoup de choses parce que j'ai été
éduqué dans ce sens mais parents m'ont
toujours dit quand un pays t'apporte
quelque chose il faut redonner
redistribuer une partie à la population
alors vous vous et définissez comme un
Africain blanc et puis il y a un
président qui est mort qui s'appelait
Mongo et qui a écrit blanc
il y a quelques années c'était en
2001 qu'il a écrit ce livre vous l'avez
connu lui le rencontrer quelquefois oui
un homme remarquable en
Occident et en Afrique on n'est pas
toujours avec beaucoup de chefs d'État
en Afrique africain sont mal vu ou
mauvaise image en Europe bon Occident
mais en Afrique ils ont pas toujours une
bonne image non plus non mais
quand même une bonne image vers la fin
il a une image qui est un peu dégradée
quoi alors vous avez écrit un livre
qui s'appelle un siècle de rêve qui est
disponible aux éditions du Cherche-Midi
vous décrivez toute votre parcours
justement le parcours de votre père de
vos aïeux en Afrique et vous êtes
de ceux qui disent l'Afrique c'est
l'avenir de l'Europe qu'est-ce qui vous
permet de dire ça
parce qu'on est en Afrique on trouve
tout
il y a les mines les réseaux au monde
particulièrement Congo
on a toute cette richesse les forêts on
trouve tout ce qu'on veut en Afrique il
suffit de le développer d'avoir les
bonnes volonté avec une bonne gestion
mais en Europe qu'est-ce qui reste on a
tout délocalisé quand on voit ce qui se
passe maintenant on a plus rien
industrie manufactoriaire presque tout
était délocalisé
et on se dit qu'est-ce qui va se passer
dans le futur or que le futur était
l'Europe parce que l'Europe à l'époque
avait des bonnes relations avec
l'Afrique elle avait des entrepreneurs
qui investissaient qui développaient qui
crée de l'empois c'est-à-dire que la
création d'emploi ça a des missions de
la pauvreté les gens se plaisent de
rester là-bas des gens ne le connaissent
à mon parti en Europe c'était le
maintenant on parle du rêve européen
mais peut-être que demain on aura nos
rêves africain c'est-à-dire que vous
pensez qu'un jour il y a des Européens
qui vont les tester en Afrique oui parce
que le jour l'Afrique va se développer
avec l'aide de l'Europe où sont les de
l'Europe elle va se développer vous êtes
sûr de ça je suis sûr
parce que des gens viennent de plus en
plus de bonnes volonté vous avez des
gens vous avez une classe moyenne qui a
quitté l'Afrique ou des intellectuels
qui voyaient qui font des brillantes
études des brillants ils ont des
punitions Canada on dépense en
Angleterre même position à l'extérieur
mais ces gens ont envie de revenir ouais
mais le jour ils reviennent ou les
autres vont rester ils vont développer
chez eux et à ce moment-là vous allez
voir que ce pays va repartir ils vont
repartir toute l'Afrique va repartir en
force le Congo particulièrement avec
toutes ces richesses qu'elle a le ciel
était bien gouvernée une bonne
gouvernance on arrivera à développer ce
pays d'une façon magistral mais il faut
autoriser aussi qu'il y a des
investisseurs qui viennent qui a des
lois qui respectent et plus il y aura
des investisseurs plus on aura une
meilleure éthique aussi les gens seront
obligés d'éditer parce que les
entreprises qui viennent sérieuses
d'Europe on éthique qui doivent la
respecter parce qu'en Europe on est
quand même surveillé donc quand on a
l'Afrique du Prophète activité ça mais
il faut aussi dans ce domaine que les
banques
puisse suivre et accompagner je joue pas
le jeu les banques mais bon on ne joue
plus le jeu aujourd'hui au contraire
quand je vois que européenne européenne
et quand je vois en Belgique
ils ferment les comptes des résidents
africains et pas retourné à mon
congolais
et d'un côté on dit investisseur en
Afrique et d'un côté on dit on dit le
contraire on fait le contraire
alors même qui se pose alors dites-moi
un peu comment voulez-vous développer
alors je me pose la question est-ce que
c'est bon son qu'on puisse avec les
États ou les États sont qu'on puisse
avec les banques pour maintenir
l'Afrique en étant pauvreté pour des
raisons qui leur sont pour votre avis
l'Occident mais en Afrique en état
pauvreté je me pose la question c'est
vous qui dites ça c'est incroyable ça
oui mais je me pose la question parce
que même ces conflits qui se passent là
s'il y avait s'il y avait des
développements du pays on n'aurait pas
tous saisi tous ces problèmes
avec une bonne gouvernance mais
justement alors justement il y a parce
que vous dites l'Afrique très bien elle
a cette richesse elle a une démographie
incroyable donc une main d'oeuvre elle a
cette jeunesse sous-sol elle est jeune
alors qui est intéressante moins de 25
ans de moyenne d'âge pourquoi pas
l'utiliser si il y a de développement en
Afrique qui se font tous vous avez toute
une main d'oeuvre à disposition que vous
n'avez plus ici mais vous avez mis le
doigt sur quelque chose que vous dites
il y a une mauvaise gouvernance aussi
mais c'est pas de la faute non plus si
ça se développe pas les chefs d'État des
des leaders africains c'est pour ça
qu'il faut développer le pays et plus il
y aura des investisseurs sérieux qui
viennent
moi il y aura de corruption
automatiquement et je crois que c'est ça
qui compte aujourd'hui victime de la
corruptions
pakistanais qui débarque chez nous
maintenant
chez eux il y a aucune règle donc la
concurrence est quand même compliqué
c'est-à-dire que nous on a des règles
éthiques les Européens et les nouveaux
naviguer là-dedans les Turcs tout ça il
se moque complètement des règles parce
que chez eux il n'y a pas de problème
mais les problèmes de gouvernance par
exemple le président
congolais de RDC mais on sait très bien
que il y a régulièrement des accusations
de mauvaises gouvernance en Afrique et
que c'est une des raisons faut pas se
leigner quand même de cette Afrique René
Dumont disait qu'elle était mal partie
je reviens toujours à créer de l'emploi
sur place des gens ne partiraient pas
donc il y aurait une meilleure
gouvernance aussi et en plus il faut
former les gens bon il n'y a plus
tellement d'éducation alors un pays sans
éducation n'a pas d'amis je crois que
c'est ça qui vous remette l'éducation en
place les soins de santé et
l'autosuffisance alimentaire si on
arrivait pas de développement à ça ne
fut-ce que l'éducation des gens si vous
êtes des gens éduqué ils vont pas
accepter tout ce qui se passe alors que
c'est facile de maintenir en état dans
un état de pauvreté ou dans un état
d'autoritarisme s'il n'y a pas
d'éducation je crois que c'est quand
même une des bases bien sûr à développer
et ça les gens qui comprennent vous avez
des pays qui ont bien compris vous avez
le Sénégal si je prends l'exemple du
Sénégal la modèle pour vous qui marche
très bien la Zambie depuis quelques
temps
avec une démocratie bien respectée donc
il y a d'autres pays qui se développent
et qui se développent avec force
combien de salariés avez-vous monsieur
forest actuellement là plus ou moins
10000 on a diminué de la moitié sur le
territoire congolais vous avez diminué
de la moitié pourquoi parce que la mine
nous ont été on a été nationalisés dans
les mines donc on a perdu les
erreurs de gouvernance quand même par
exemple vous étiez dans un pays qui
s'appelle Zaïre longtemps il y a eu ce
qu'on a appelé la zaïsisation du pays on
dépossède les propriétaires de leurs
biens ça c'était la grande erreur de
Mobutu quand il a pris le pouvoir les
cinq premières années il était fabuleux
le meilleur partait très fort bobo
il est là voilà
il a créé cette arrimination mal
conseillée parce qu'il a voulu créer
très vite une classe moyenne c'est au
tour dans des années 70
il a voulu créer une classe moyenne très
vite il a dit on va distribuer les biens
qui était une erreur parce qu'il a
décapité toutes l'économie et toute la
France Culture qui existait et depuis ce
moment-là le pays a commencé à sombrer
dans les ténèbres comme aujourd'hui ou
c'est terrible et vous en êtes jamais
relevé enfin le Zaïre ne s'en est jamais
relevé parce qu'après les ceux qui ont
suivi nous n'ont pas essayé de
nécessairement de redresser le pays
Kabila et que les moyens rfis le père
est dedans il est arrivé il a toujours
cru que le pays était très riche et
quand il s'est rendu compte il est
assassin
le fils il avait d'autres idées avec un
conseiller il a mal entraîné et alors
ils ont fait que deux trois expatriés
des toutes sortes d'autres personnes à
une corruption au maximum dans le dans
un intérêt purement financier donc
essayons tous les articles chinois bref
c'est plus facile de travailler avec eux
qu'avec les Européens
je suis investisseur français belge
allemand je vais venir en Afrique et en
Afrique République démocratique du Congo
qu'est-ce que vous dites pour me
persuader mais je dis qu'il ne doit pas
hésiter de venir parce qu'il y a moyen
de faire beaucoup de choses avec une
main d'oeuvre pléthore et qui n'est pas
si cher que ça par rapport à l'Europe
ailleurs or il y a des domaines qui
n'allaient pas exploité cette main
d'oeuvre justement
leur donner de l'entre avant
correctement
avec de bonnes conditions mais il y a
des domaines qui est encore tout à fait
vierge qu'il faut développer que là il y
a potentiel énorme si je prends la Groix
industrie
tout est en faire moi je vois nous avons
commencé la grande industrie déjà
quelques années mais nous sommes
maintenant presque 4000 personnes rien
que là-dedans
on a 10000 hectares de maïs on a 1500
hectares de soya on va commencer le blé
maintenant on a une biscuiterie qui
produit plus ou moins avec les capacités
qu'on est occupe pas à mettre on va
arriver à 36000 tonnes de muscu par donc
ça fait quand même aujourd'hui on
produit rien que pour les la région du
catalan pour début de 1 milliard de
biscuits est-ce que vous êtes pas
handicapé par le réchauffement
climatique par la sécheresse tout ça ça
handicap pas votre activité non parce
que on a
qui est très bon on peut dire ce qu'on
veut on a quand même deux saisons mais
il y a de l'eau partout donc il y a
l'irrigation
qui compense le climat dont on choisit
les ce qu'il faut pour les plantations
qui nécessaires en fonction de du climat
et des terres mais il y a quand même un
climat qui est assez antioxydantal assez
anti-français Antibes en Afrique
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas quelque
chose que vous redoutez et qui pourrait
à terme va faire que justement toutes
ces exploitations tout ce que vous dites
là les Africains disent bah non c'est à
nous tout ça on veut plus que ce soit
européen qui gère ça non ils peuvent
faire participer les Africains et pour
les prendre comme partout vous pouvez
prendre l'ordonnée par participation
aussi ouais donc moyen de trouver des
formules ils ont une participation chez
vous les Africains ils ont des
participations
donc
il faut il faut choisir le juste milieu
comment développer ses activités sur
place ce sentiment antioxyntalon que
vous dites
provient déjà par le passé l'erreur
qu'on a fait on est arrivé de bon on
était conquérant
on est arrivé comme des honneurs d'ordre
on a supprimé toute leur coutumes leur
tradition ça c'est une erreur la
religion c'est une erreur on a imposé
nos religions on a imposé nos coutumes
or qu'il fallait leur laisser leur
coutume leur union mais développer le
pays comme on a fait l'économie en
raison en respectant leurs traditions
leur tradition je crois que c'était
quand même important ça c'est la grande
erreur de la colonisation pour vous
certainement parce que malgré tout ils
sont ils ont été ils sont sensibles à ça
bon et bien qu'on revient tout doucement
à certaines traditions donc
automatiquement il se réacaparent
ceux qui ne leur passé oui il faut il
faut leur laisser et je crois que plus
en plus maintenant on a continué il y a
l'indépendance depuis 60 ans mais on
vient toujours un peu donner des leçons
or il faut traiter avec eux comme des
partenaires des gars légales
gagnant-gagnant et pas dire on va vous
donner on va vous dire ce qu'il faut
faire non c'est toujours le discours que
vous avez tenu par exemple avec les
autorités congolaises oui moi je parle
franchement et que je n'ai pas de
problème
vous n'avez jamais cherché à influencer
sur le plan politique contenu de votre
puissance économique de le gouvernement
les gouvernements congolais jamais donc
elles sont en faveur de vos affaires
quoi pour que non
il respecte beaucoup et justement les
autorités respectent les gens qui
investissent et qui créent d'emploi qui
diminuent la pauvreté et qui font le
social ce que nous faisons c'est pour ça
que nous sommes forts respecter un peu
dans toute l'Afrique moi quand je voyage
en Afrique je suis respecté reçu partout
je vais et j'ai envie de voir un chef
d'État il me reçoit parce que notre nom
et notre réputation est passé autre
toutes les frontières donc on n'a pas on
n'a pas de problème là-dessus qu'est-ce
qui manque à l'Afrique aujourd'hui pour
être plus attractif que jamais
mais bon on fait tellement aussi une
mauvaise publicité sur la fréquent en
Europe toute la presse est tout à fait
toujours contre les médias sont les
médias responsables en partie et les ONG
parce que les ONG aussi c'est une bise
c'est du business pour aller parce que
tous les fonds qui reçoivent mais si
vous n'avez pas des activités industrer
l'eau d'affaires reviennent ils
commencent à donner la des aides des
alimentations des choses mais bon ils
vont acheter pour distribuer
laissons les gens apprenons les gens à
travailler et à produire produire voilà
bon et donc vous avez une dent contre
les ONG je trouve que j'ai lu d'ailleurs
dans votre livre dans quelques ONG qui
sont valables mais des ONG qui viennent
et qui accusent des gens
faussement rien que pour de business
c'est tout vous avez été victime de ça
j'ai été vite
montré à la vindique populaire
ton pauvre mais pas en Afrique mais en
Europe oui
et donc il y a une mauvaise presse qu'il
faut absolument changer voilà vous
essayez de vous y employer avec ce livre
justement qui essaye d'essayer une image
j'essaye de de défendre de défendre
l'Afrique parce que je fais un Africain
blanc vous l'avez dit
et je crois qu'il est important de que
les gens comprennent que l'Afrique n'est
pas ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on dit mais il faut l'Afrique est
tout à fait différente quand on la voit
vraiment
de l'intérieur et voir ce qu'on peut
faire
vous avez fréquenté vous l'avez dit
beaucoup de chefs d'État beaucoup de
responsables africains est-ce que
quelques-uns d'entre eux vous ont plus
particulièrement
impressionnés marqué ou que vous avez
qui ont suscité votre
votre sympathie votre admiration
quand j'ai fait allusion au Sénégal bon
c'est un gore quelqu'un de Léopold Sédar
Senghor le premier président du Sénégal
de la République du Sénégal il y avait
quand même un pays pauvre avec peu de
richesse en sous-sol qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait oui il a développé l'éducation il
en a fait des élites
vous retrouver aujourd'hui il est là oui
que vous retrouvez aujourd'hui presque
dans le monde entier à des postes
importants dans toutes les organismes
internationaux
et c'est devenu une force aujourd'hui le
Sénégal se développe très bien pour vous
avez un tout dire que j'admire beaucoup
à de Dieu c'était le successeur de
Léopold Sédar un homme remarquable
brillante dans les sommets
internationaux mais
c'était quelqu'un de très bien et qui a
quand même créé le Milan démocratie au
Sénégal c'est vrai
il a fait de la Francophonie une force
politique quand même importante alors
justement une certaine influence
aujourd'hui la francophonie la disparu
après le président Diouf ouais
la francophonie ça pourrait être un
instrument de développement justement
qui permet aux pays francophones
d'Afrique de davantage et de mieux se
développer de mieux coopérer entre eux
parce qu'il y avait un meilleur dialogue
mec avec l'Occident l'Europe
donc
je n'ai rien contre le Rwanda mais vous
mettez une anglophone dans la tête de
cette organisme il y a un problème parce
que
aujourd'hui la personne qui est en
charge de la Francophonie dans le monde
de l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie est une rwandaise et le
Rwanda est un pays francophone à
l'origine à l'origine mais ils devenait
anglophones
oui bien sûr donc et ça on sent très
bien que
du fait que la façon dont les Anglais
ont travaillé avec l'Afrique était
légèrement différente quand même avec
il donne moins de leçons et vous voyez
bien que la colonisation britannique a
été plus a été très différente de
l'alcoolisation totalement francophone
la colonisation totalement différente
alors la colonisation belge il faut le
dire c'est que très longtemps le Congo
était la propriété au 19e siècle
carrément du roi du roi des Belges
tout à fait
carbolie l'esclavage qui aboli néanmoins
l'esclavagisme
et que après bon on essaie de développer
à donner le Congo à l'État belge et en
très peu de temps on fait une merveille
ouais il faut leur il faut les
quand même le Congo quand vous pensez
qu'en 1960 pb
= au Canada mais supérieur à la Corée du
Sud à l'Afrique du Sud oui c'est quand
même
impressionnant impressionnant c'était
quand même la première puissance
africaine après après l'Afrique du Sud
or elle est sûrement dépasser
l'Afrique du Sud
donc tout ça c'est dû quand même à
l'incurie de ceux qui ont fait la
décolonisation la Belgique a mal préparé
la décolleration il faut dire ce qu'est
elle a construit le pays par en
construisant la base de la pyramide vers
le Web mais n'avait pas eu fait les
élites assez tôt pour pouvoir diriger le
pays donc les troubles d'aider
l'indépendance trois quatre jours après
les émeutes les révolutions non dans
tout le pays donc tout ce qui était
infracture qui devait rester en place
l'administration est partie ouais le
pays se retrouvait sans plus personne
pour la gérer
vous parlez de culture
est-ce que vous avez un artiste préféré
en Afrique moi j'aime beaucoup chérie
samba d'accord on a beaucoup aidé
qui est un photographe photographe oui
vous investissez vous-même beaucoup dans
la culture africaine beaucoup nous avons
vous aider des artistes
ces artistes là il y en a d'autres qu'on
les a découvert qui aujourd'hui sont
devenus de grandes réputation lesquelles
mais logique
il y en a d'autres encore qui sont au
Canada non nous avons une galerie qui
est au musée de lombashique qui s'occupe
uniquement dans la promotion des
artistes congolais chic est une des
grandes villes que la deuxième ville de
la République démocratique du Congo qui
est au sud qui est aussi tout à force du
Congo de la République démocratique du
Congo vos enfants aujourd'hui
s'occupent de vos affaires
et ils ont la même je dirais le même
virus de la nationalité congolaise que
vous
je pense qu'ils aiment bien l'Afrique
aussi ils sont là
je pense ils sont ils sont bien
peut-être pas le même sentiment que moi
ils sont ils sont ils restent africains
quand même ouais parce que
ils sentent qu'il y a une remise en
question justement
de l'Occident sur place ils ont quelques
craintes
oui évidemment avec tout ce qui se passe
maintenant avec ces systèmes bancaires
et les conditions qu'on met de plus en
plus pour les personnes
[Musique]
les conditions d'éthiques et autres
on les respecte mais enfin il faut pas
les pompiers dans un extrême
il y a des choses qui se passent en
Europe bien sûr bon non bien sûr soyons
honnêtes vous êtes optimiste pour
l'avenir de l'Afrique ou de vous l'avez
dit moi je reste optimiste
vous êtes un afro optimiste je suis un
afro je suis toujours optimiste par
principe je crois qu'il faut toujours
être optimiste il faut toujours rêver de
quelque chose si vous rêvez pas vous ne
construisez rien
genre Arthur forest merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]